new york ap
un supporter
et il ya une boutique varvatos à la
place du club cbgb c'est vrai le seul
endroit où ça vibre encore aujourd'hui
c'est philadelphie wf chirales je viens
d'emménager au top et thomas web
pourquoi tu me suis troublé thomas j'ai
eu une mauvaise journée c'est quoi son
don
suis dingue de toi moi aussi je t'aime
mais ne dis surtout pas comment ni
pourquoi pourquoi ça serait mal comment
tu prendre il faut que l'oeil alice qui
est une chose encore plus effrayante que
tu avec toi laquelle ne plus être avec
trop comment je peux arriver à ça laisse
la vie prendre le dessus trouve le pont
credo et font ce qu est ce que mon père
fait ici il a avec qui j'en sais rien
mais c'est pas ma mère
c'est elle l'autre femme
excusez moi vous savez pas qui je suis
ici je sais à huy vous n'arrêtez pas de
me suivre
vous êtes le fils des tannes vous voulez
qu'il se sépare de ma mère vous pouvez
avoir n'importe quel homme
ah oui même vous quoi j'ai jamais
rencontré quelqu'un comme elle la façon
dont se présente trahit souvent vous
sentirez moi j'ai envie de quoi la faire
l'amour avec moi
faire l'amour avec vous c'est vrai c'est
quoi ce genre de questions c'est une
très belle femme elle couche avec mon
père tu peux être plus discrète
tu es candidat marc tu ne sais pas
comment le monde fonctionne je sais au
moins un truc c'est quoi
[Musique]
parce que c'est avec elle ça tu regardes
tu veux qu'il se passe quoi tente avis
il ya quelque chose que je devrais
savoir quelque chose que tu as à me dire
tu fais ça pour autre chose tu peux
savoir quoi
par provocation
c'est parti en vrille qu'il est
exactement comme ils ont gagné thomas
j'essaie de m'en sortir je n'arrive pas
tu le sais bien
le seul moyen c'est d'aller jusqu'au
bout
la vie tout en fait deux arcs de choix
le groupe est ce que côtoie le tragique
ti fera pas exception
[Musique]